[Music]
from the moment she's born a man's
daughter is the center of his universe
you give her love you give her
encouragement you watch her grow into a
strong confident woman and then one day
you come face to face with the love of
her life my god well looks like she
works out quite a bit step you get them
up here please hello surprise sent her
Christmas card it's all you happy
holidays and everything it says Happy
Holidays I gave the guy that Christmas
card I know he put happy holidays on
there
I guess that's on me forever now turns
out her boyfriend is this internet
billionaire Laird has literally no
filter but he's a really good guy lemma
that night in the hot tub staff open up
like a flower you should have seen it I
shouldn't have seen it but now I feel
like I have no father would want their
daughter with this guy my instinct is to
hug you right now good night I don't
know what is issues or oh my I feel like
I'm so normal
I don't like bodyguards around so I just
like do stop training these strange as
they come the reaction side is getting
bigger and what happened to is the
evasive parkour
and on Christmas Day I'm gonna ask
Stephie to marry me and I really like
your blessing
ya know just give me a couple days when
you over by Christmas morning you're
gonna be calling me son I'm gonna call
you dad don't think that's gonna happen
I think it's gonna dad I know it won't
dad it was nothing but dad that that
stop that dad what are you talking about
yes sir you could be dating anyone my
lair he's really happy he is wrapping
his tentacles around every member of his
family because of his influence your
mother has lost her mind this is not
someone we want our daughter Mary I am
gonna take this octopus down you're
gonna say anything that Stephanie about
the proposal right drug Laird spying on
us mess with me
[Music]
of her life
[ __ ] Fleming's are in the house
yes oh my god [ __ ] yeah
looks like he barks I'll clip it step
you get him up here